um when he was three years old
his older siblings forgot him at the
park
when they came back to get him they
found him walking home at a stoplight
surrounded by a pack of dogs that would
not let him cross the street
I assume that since he's here he
survived so everyone please welcome
David
uh thank you appreciate the time to to
be here today and talk to you guys about
the r Studio ecosystems the critical
part of NASA's analytical capabilities
my apologies to our studio I guess I
should change that to the deposit but
I'd already had these slides done so I
left them alone
so let me ask you really quick how many
are from a government agency
all right so you might relate to some of
this there's not going to be any code in
this it's more about the Journey of how
we try to create our analytical
architecture and the things that I've
had to go through
so first thing so hi
usually I want to just make sure that
everybody understands you know we're
here just to have a good time we're here
to just to understand what we can do
within the analytical Community one of
the things I do want to tell you about
this presentation this is not a
presentation about R versus python when
I first announced this talk everybody's
called great we're going to hear why R
is better than python this is not that
kind of a talk it is how we can use RN
python together to be able to do this
within the architecture because I have a
team that's made up of both R and python
developers so
so who am I and what do I do
um very long sentence you know paragraph
here basically on the head of analytics
for human capital at Nasa overseeing the
analytical architecture when I first
came up to headquarters back in 2019
they asked me to take a look at how we
can improve our analytical architecture
make it more modern because we had a lot
of things going wrong with this within
the business side of NASA
so money you know NASA gets a good chunk
of money you know not not as much as a
lot of agencies but more than some
most of that money rightfully so goes to
things like supporting the International
Space Station climate science you know
getting Orion up and around the Moon and
back and making sure that we can get to
Mars eventually on the business side of
things where I'm at where I've grown up
working within NASA within the Ocio now
human capital I've done some work in
Knowledge Management you know you're
thinking about ocfo the procurement we
don't get as much money so we kind of
have to do with what we have and make
things work as best we can
so when I first started this journey
several years ago my laptop on desktop
at that time was my development
environment we didn't have Cloud
resources we didn't have anything to do
and our data pipeline of course because
of that was not automated
the automation was me going every
morning and clicking run the script in
order to run the data run the calculator
do the calculations and then send that
somewhere so that it could be do some
more calculations and then back to the
presentation layer and that presentation
layer was basically again my laptop I
would go from meeting to meeting going
here this is what your figures look like
and go to the next meeting here this is
what it looks like it was really very
very
disheartening I guess at the time just
to try to do all of this and go we've
got to do better we've got so many new
modern Technologies out there why can't
we do better in here again it came down
to resources so what can we do to really
make this work
so some of the other things we were
missing of course lack of access to
authoritative data sources
many times here's how the conversation
would go I would knock on the door I
need access to the last 10 years of
people data great which data do you need
I need I don't know I don't know what
data you have can you just give me the
data oh no I need to know what data you
need in order for me to give it to you I
said okay do you have a data dictionary
what's that okay
all right let's see what we can do so
over the years we finally started to
work through these people I've got them
to understand the data governance
process understand what a data owner is
what the data what the different data
roles are got them to give us a data
dictionary so that we could start
getting and I finally finally this was
exciting a couple of weeks a couple of
months ago in a meeting
the data of the person that oversees all
the data I.T in human capital in the
data anything that David and his team
want they can get no questions asked and
I said Thank you so that finally was
able to get that kind of a data and for
those of you who have that trouble know
how hard that can be that was the good
news the not so good news is I'm still
working firewall issues across some of
the different organizations to make sure
I can even get access to that data and
of course because of that we didn't have
any data Lake
or any way to store our AIML curated
data sets ready for analytics they were
still grabbing the data from a SQL
server or some other type of database
putting it into our laptop now we're
starting to do it more on cloud
resources and doing the transformation
doing it we're slowly working through
that back in 2019
uh with the well actually 2020 now I
guess when with the start of covid we
realized that we needed to be able to
provide data and that kind of gave us an
impetus and a little bit of funding to
start developing what we call the
enterprise data platform and I'll show
you some architecture here that we're
working through
that I'm trying to promote to Ocio to
say this is kind of the things that we
need what can you develop for us as we
go through that and of course through
this there's no aim or devops and no
presentation capabilities other than my
laptop and going around from meeting the
meeting Click Share made it a lot easier
when we finally started using that to be
able to click into a board rather than
having to show it on my laptop
so what do we need
well what I need is a collaborative
development environment that supports
both R and python because I've got some
computer scientists that have turned
into Data scientists that started off
learning python I've got some i o
psychologists in life sciences who
utilize r so we've got to make sure they
can talk together and one thing that I
that I really like about quarto to to
Shirley's presentation is the fact that
you can do both R and python in there
and actually share those presentations
of documents by freezing
the code so when you send it to somebody
that you send your R code to somebody is
working on python it doesn't try to run
their code if they don't have r on there
they can do their python code freeze it
and send it back to you and it really
works well on collaborating across teams
like that we also need a modern data
pipeline something where I don't I can
actually do a script put it up there on
a job and let it run automatically and
set it through that we need the data
Lake of course for those AIML curated
data sets the more Cloud resources than
a platform those are the things I was
asking for I didn't think it was a whole
lot but it's taken me several years to
try to get to this point
so here's kind of what we're looking for
our future State as you can see here
we're looking here to try to get some
kind of AIML
devsec Ops operations here so we've
asked for
um in this case we've got a they're
developed what they called appdat which
is an application data platform uh which
allows us to utilize various containers
image containers from the kubernetes
cluster to be able to do all of this
with with configuration management with
Git lab so it's starting to start to get
a little bit easier so that we can share
our code and go across that the biggest
thing here was this area right here
opening up the firewalls between our
authoritative data source our data Lake
and utilizing our Tools in our studio uh
altarex for some low code low code type
things and then putting that through
some ml devops with vetiver as well as
kubeflow over to our presentation layers
utilizing both Tableau or actually
Tableau power bi now and the r Studio
connect system with all the various
capabilities in there all of that has
given us a freedom to be able to utilize
many different tools
I'm not locked into one thing so those
who know code can work in R and python
uh in SQL and some other things those
who rather not work with code can work
with alteryx we're taking a look right
now at data Fusion uh which is a Google
on gcp as a data prep type thing there's
also Tableau prime or some other tools
but there's definitely a lot of
capabilities but what I really what I
think is really important is this bottom
layer right here when you're talking to
your organization you have to have that
r d layer we were so far behind the
technology stack because we weren't
looking at it over time that it made it
really difficult to get caught up so
I've tried to get make sure that we
understand we've got to set aside
funding for some type of research and
development to understand and learn how
that technology is changing over time
and how we may be able to use some of
that otherwise we'll come we'll be here
five years from now trying to re-up our
technology and taking a long time again
because we didn't prepare for what's out
there and what's new
so again going back to the development
platform now what I have is the rstudio
Pro or server Pro out there that allows
me to do many many things again across a
different platform we've got of course
the rstudio IDE we can do Jupiter
notebooks Jupiter lab python or
um I don't think what I have on there is
visual code which is also now part of
the rstudio system to be able to do that
and it allows my my developers to create
so many different things in various
different platforms and web
architectures not only do we have the
shity but we can do streamlit flies
plotly and now with the uh the new
creation of the shiny for python
and what is that web I forget the name
of that now that allows you to put that
actual shiny application on somebody's
website or browse to send them the shiny
app without having to put on a connect
server I forget that web technology name
from the acronym right now and I
apologize for that it's my 60 years of
being on this Earth I forget something
sometimes
so what we do now what we have is our
data pipeline working through here so
now I'm able to get to my authoritative
data sources and extract that data
utilizing some type of you know
container some type of script something
now that I could automate either on the
connect server which allows me to put up
their script and set a job or through a
container on the kubernetes cluster that
allow me to do the same thing but all
that auto allows me to take that raw
data do some transformation within R and
or Python and turn that into what we
call trusted data now that data is
taking everything we've had we've
cleaned it up we've taken our raw data
cleaned it up put it in the format we
need to be able to say this is the if
this is what we're going to use for
analysis it's been cleaned it's been
formatted it's ready to go then we can
start doing some modeling statistical
analysis create our pipelines create
everything else we need for the analysis
and turn that into curated data sets
that curated then becomes what we
utilize to share by create by taking
that curated data set I can now put a
API on top of that using plumber or fast
API within again within the Eco that our
studio ecosystem to allow other
organizations to share our curated data
set that's been cleaned it's been
removed of any kind of sensitive
information or any pii and they can we
can now share that out to other
organizations again through our
presentation layer
yeah this is still kind of new for us
we're still trying to develop this with
the ml Ops so I just took basically the
information straight off of the website
of what vetiver does but it allows us to
really start utilizing our our
development of our models whether we're
doing a nutrition model or time to hire
model or we're taking a look at the
engagement of our employees
we can now use vetiver to create those
models to to keep track them to monitor
them to update them again both in R and
or python
either way however however our
developers create them and then make
them accessible and we can make them
accessible uh through many different
combination or many different techniques
here again whether we're allowing
somebody to connect to that model
through their development environment or
creating a API through the plumber or
some or fast API again to allow us to be
able to Showcase some of those things so
so it really starting to open up what we
can do
and really for minimal cost compared to
some of the other things we're trying
that we were trying to do
um and we're talking right now you know
a couple of million dollars we've been
able to utilize to set all of our
environment up uh which may sound like a
lot but when you're really thinking
about the what the organizations spend
uh it's really helping the in the
business side of the institutional side
develop something with minimal cost and
able to maintain this very easily
so what does that allow us to do well
as we deliver our product we've got a
high volume of request but ad hoc and
recurrent analysis that we do we get I
get Congressional calls that that from
my Superior saying Congress wants this
we need it now so those things happen
all the time so we need to be able to
move quickly get that data through that
or we have things that we're constantly
doing from our metrics from our deia or
data component from a demographics
component all of that we have to take an
eye and look at how we're going to
develop these things this environment
allows us to work very rapidly
it allows us to think about what we're
doing and repeat and reproduce the
analysis we're doing because we're able
to share across different uh different
platforms as well as across different
Developers
so when we deliver our products we then
have something like this which is more
of a dashboard a landing page this
particular landing page is the Tableau
landing page that actually connects to
the connect server that allows us to
show our shiny applications or other
applications that we have on there it
also actually leads to a shiny a landing
page on the connect server so we have to
we're trying to mimic this on the
connect server so you have two entry
points to be able to do that and these
this is basically broken down into
different categories
and we try to we try to make sure we
curate these things so they're similar
in in look and feel as well as what's
available to the end users so the end
users when they go to one of our
dashboards or one of our products
they're going to have a place where they
can give us feedback tell us what's good
what's wrong what we need to do or ask
for a requests they can watch a tutorial
how to use the dashboard as well as to
make the important thing is look at the
data dictionaries and documentation of
how that analysis was done because too
many times we get our reports and go out
there and people make up their own
conclusions we need to make sure they
understand the assumptions do they
understand what's going on they
understand how the data was pulled where
you can actually generalize this data
against you know maybe it's only for a
particular population not for the entire
population so we we try to have all that
information there so people can utilize
this and again this makes it repeatable
reproducible so year after year after
year we're comparing the same data
across that time frame rather than
different data which we've done in the
past many times using laptops you know
one person would create an analysis on
one laptop another person on another
laptop and and they go well the numbers
don't match up why we spend hours and
hours trying to figure out well you
didn't do this on when you when you
transformed this data set we did and
that's why we're getting this this way
we're all using the same curated data
set we are talking about the same type
of data so that helps there
so
what's really cool and what I really
like again I talked a little bit about
plumber API plumber Tableau and fast API
we have again within the team there's a
group of both data scientists and data
analysts and these data scientists and
data analysts that do different things
the data analysts primarily work on
business intelligence type things on the
analytical kind of levels they're more
looking at the descriptive and maybe
some of the diagnostic type capabilities
that they're doing so they're not really
interested in actually working with the
algorithms developing the algorithm
doing the models and of course the data
scientists are more looking across the
entire platform but also the predictive
and the prescriptive side of the
analytics so they're creating these
models these visualizations these
different capabilities that we can turn
into an a tableau extension via the apis
and through Tableau you can load that
into the Tableau analysis so now we've
got both the combination of Tableau and
visualization with some R capabilities
Tableau is great but there's some
limitations to it you can't send data
back and forth
so I can't update anything if I want to
so through through some of these
extensions we can help with some of that
so this is some of the products we've
created just from our survey data taking
a look at our Employee Engagement our
federal employee Viewpoint surveys on
how we do this and for those of you who
in the government and know that we've
actually taken our fam survey in-house
so now we're able to do this and get the
data much quicker and get the results
back out to our to our managers uh in in
a month rather than several months that
are usually through OMB
no but this is the great technology we
started working with this probably about
two three months two three months ago
and really starting to develop it I've
got some of my data scientists trying to
develop models that we can then post on
some of these tableaus uh sites here
so but
as I mentioned Tableau can't do
everything the connect server really
comes into play here where we can do a
lot of different things on the top left
hand side over here this is more of an
application that walks somebody through
we're able to Showcase you know I've got
a I've got a a
actuals that I'm looking for for my
hiring how did I do you know across my
plan did that that plan actually come to
fruition so through a series of
questions they can answer these
questions it'll run through the model
and show them how they're they're hiring
plan so actors came out or other
deformation but but because this is a a
presentation component that allows you
to do many different things than just
dashboards the bottom left over here is
a road map created uh within this
connect server that's interactive it
makes it makes it very easy to to see
what we're working on when we're working
on it update it very easily and again
connectable to anybody within the
network
top right it's a book
as uh Shirley was talking about with
quarto marked down before that but poor
tone now you can create books present
this presentation is actually a quarter
presentation that I'm working on here
but you can create books that would
create a knowledge based uh specifically
for my human capital data scientist
that's shareable on the connect server
they can go through there and find
information on various topics they can
update it we can maintain it so we've
got this huge knowledge base of what
we're working on and how we've done
things that anybody can within the
organization go look at it and try to
understand how we did things and learn
from themselves how to do things and
then finally of course if we have
metrics and developments down here the
models will create and generate and run
on a daily basis and show the
information so that entire ecosystem
just really helps us understand our
pipeline a lot easier we can work
through that pipeline send the data from
the authoritative raw data all the way
through the presentation layer wow and I
should have started with it this is this
isn't a sales pitch you know for for our
studio or anything it's really more
about what are the capabilities you have
this is what I had to work with I have
these these capabilities in-house I've
been able to add to them and then just
part of the architecture we still have
other things within that architecture we
have of course kubeflow we have orchids
that we're looking at which is another
pipeline we've got altarex so there's
many different things to make this up
but this is a critical component that
answered quite a few pieces for what we
were trying to do from the data
development
to the data flow to the actual looking
at the presentation layer and the in the
devops so it's a lot of good things that
are capable there and again with
relatively inexpensive uh capabilities
to do that allows your organizations to
work together across very different
mediums
so lastly I want to thank you I look
forward to connecting with any of you
that feel free to reach out to me on
LinkedIn but I do want to leave you with
one cool fact several years ago with the
JPL before curiosity landed on March and
I was talking to some of the uh the
developers there of the Rover and they
told me the story where they had asked
NASA management and they could put a JPL
logo on the Rover and management said no
nothing but a NASA sticker can go on
there no JPL logo so the engineers being
Engineers say we're not going to take
that so what they did is on on one of
the wheels there invoice code
it's a j a p and an L so every time it
runs on the Martian surface it leaves
the morse code JPL on the Martian
surface so they got their JPL out their
kudos to them for figuring out how to do
that without showing up anybody but it's
I thought it was a pretty good idea what
they did and show some of the Ingenuity
and things we can do at Nasa thank you I
appreciate your time